avec des symboles de la République qui
ont été attaqués parfois d'ailleurs de
manière organisée
presque coordonnée
a été incendié à Cergy c'est le
commissariat qui a été pris pour cible à
Neuilly-sur-Marne ce sont les 7
véhicules de la police municipale qui
ont été détruits a besoin dans le
Val-d'Oise c'est la façade d'une école
qui a été incendiée partout en France
des dizaines de bâtiments publics ont
été incendies au dégradés les gens se
révoltent avec parfois des débordements
mais ça c'est vrai de tout mouvement et
bien c'est qu'il y a une solution des
réponses à leur apporter les réponses à
leur apporter c'est le fait qu'on change
la doctrine policière qu'on reconnaisse
qu'il y a des violences policières à
Wattrelos supermarché à brûlé à
Tourcoing c'est une école privée
injustifiable le parquet considère que
les conditions légales d'usage de l'arme
ne sont pas réunis une information a été
ouverte contre un policier mais pas
contre la police et que les amalgames à
mon sens sont interdits et ils sont
dangereux Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un
appel à l'insurrection que ce tweet les
chiens de garde nous ordonnent d'appeler
au calme nous appelons à la justice
retirer l'action judiciaire contre le
pauvre Naël suspendait le policier
meurtrier sont complices qui lui a
ordonné de tirer tous ceux qui depuis
des mois critiquent la police
la justice policier justice dans dans la
même barque républicaine
sont les complices moraux et je pèse mes
mots de ceux qui
commettent ces exactions
le ciel de Nanterre assombrit par la
fumée des premiers incendies plusieurs
voitures sont en feu les CRS se
déploient autour de la préfecture cible
des caillassages quand je vois tout ce
monde là en fait il faut l'amour que
Naël a porté à tous ces gens-là il y
aura beaucoup beaucoup de monde pour une
marche pacifique
je précise bien pour une marche
pacifique la manifestation c'est pour
tenter dans le calme en début
d'après-midi juché sur cette camionnette
la mère du jeune garçon sur son t-shirt
l'inscription justice pour Naël ses
côtés également à sa Traoré la sœur
d'Adama mort suite à son interpellation
par la police en 2016 monde solennel Man
au président de la République et au
gouvernement de décréter l'état
d'urgence sans délai on n'est pas dans
ces circonstances je pense que avec tous
les élus on aura l'occasion de réitérer
l'appel au calme pas les forces de
l'ordre seront aussi mobilisées pour
qu'on évite que ce genre de situation se
reproduise devant des journalistes à la
Maison Blanche alors qu'on lui demandait
si Poutine avait été affaiblie par la
rébellion du groupe Wagner il a eu cette
réponse écoutez
même si le couvre-feu devait être
déclaré je j'ai du mal à croire qu'il
sera respecté les débris du petit
sous-marin Titan ainsi que des restes
humains présumés ont été remontés à la
surface pour être examinés des analyses
vont donc être réalisées et elles
permettront peut-être de mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé à bord de
l'appareil